Tyrel scripture today proverbs 13 11
wealth gained hastily will dwindle
but whoever gathers little by little
will increase it let's try that again
that's one you need enough proverbs 13
11 just for those of you who aren't
listening the first time wealth gained
hastily will dwindle
but whoever gathers little by little
will increase it another proverb says he
who hastens to be rich will not go
unpunished hmm hastens a stoolie that's
not a word we use today that's kind of
an old English word isn't it but what's
it mean you're in too big a freaking
hurry that's what it means you're trying
to get rich quick get-rich-quick will
not go unpunished that's what it said
and wealth gained quickly doesn't last
usually that's what this says but people
that gather wealth little by little
increase wealth the vast majority of
people who are wealthy 90 plus percent
of the people that I have met and worked
with the thousands and thousands of
millionaires I've worked with over the
years did it gradually now I'm not
against getting money quickly if you
want to do that I'm not saying you're
evil or it's bad but there are all kinds
of problems that go with it when it
comes quickly because what happens to
most of us is as we grow our wealth we
as individuals are emotionally and
spiritually maturing we are growing and
so the wealth never gets so big that it
crushes us under our our character is
strong enough to carry it as we build it
gradually and we build our character
gradually that's the only shot but you
know how many times have we seen the
young
athlete that gets money and it destroys
their life the young music artist that
gets money and it destroys their life
the young actor that gets money and
they're in rehab for the rest of their
life because they didn't have the
emotional in their case character to
carry it and it doesn't have to be young
it can be old how many times have you
heard somebody fifty five years old that
never had any money in their whole life
than they were in the lottery and it
destroys their life it wasn't a blessing
see wealth gained hastily will dwindle
he who hastens who's in a hurry to be
rich
will not go unpunished that happened to
me I got rich quick I mean I started
from nothing we graduated from college
and I got married at 22 years old by the
time I was 26 I was a millionaire how
did I do that
I borrowed at all I had a million dollar
net worth at four million dollars for
the real estate three million dollars
worth of debt 4 minus 3 is 1 I was a
millionaire and I made $250,000 that
year most 1983-1985 I mean that that's a
long time ago there's a lot of money
even then a lot of money no but it was a
house of cards I had so much debt and I
wasn't behind with anyone I wasn't late
on the payments but the bank got sold to
another bank they called our notes
because I was an idiot they signed up
and gave them the ability had a lot of
short-term notes because I was flipping
houses before there was cable TV to tell
you how I built a house of cards because
I was in a hurry to get rich and then I
was just appalled and shocked that the
house of cards fell well guess what
houses of cards do they fall all the
time there's no such thing as a
well-constructed house of cards
the point is it's fragile it's volatile
it falls in he who hastens to be rich
will not go unpunished
get-rich-quick trying to play the lotto
you get punished did you throw your
money down the toilet
you going there buy a lotto ticket you
get nothing you got nothing nothing
think about every time every action that
someone takes to become wealthy easily
and quickly usually results in
punishment this is dead on this disk
this is these scriptures are straight-up
truth and john tyler said it this way
wealth can only be accumulated by the
earnings of Industry and the savings of
frugality well well that lasts that's
all it is but you can get wealth other
ways you can get wealth by sudden fame
and get wealth by sudden you know that
you can you can hit the lottery you know
one a bazillion people do but the rest
everybody else is trying to win the
wealth that way gets punished but by
losing their money instead of investing
their money little by little will
increase your wealth that's where real
wealth comes from the highest
probability of building wealth the best
way to get rich quick is to get rich
slow hey guys thanks for watching if you
enjoyed this video click the subscribe
button to get the latest content and
check out these other great clips from
the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]